welcome back to new rock stars it's me
mt and this is a breakdown for sony
pictures morbius so let's go ahead and
take a bite into all the fun missable
details and spider-man easter eggs that
the mtu's neighbor universe has to offer
in this dark new chapter filled with
blood
sorry i just watched too much sesame
street as a child very upset that the
count did not show up in the
post-credits scene by the way what were
you thinking sony come on and also
spoilers for the whole blood-sucking
life-sucking affair that is morbius but
hey if you clicked on the video that
said morbius breakdown then i'm sure
this spoiler warning isn't needed and
the director spoiled the movie himself
so let's go ahead and sync our suckers
into the secrets of scarad leto shall we
and right off the bat the movie opens up
with blue and pink v-shaped designs
preceding the title of the film morbius
evoking the colors and font of the
mobius solo series from the 90s which i
found to be a very smart and nice design
touch with the v-shaped downwards arrows
representing the famous v-shaped design
of morbius's collar a collar that many
of morbace's victims have gotten up
close and personal with you know right
before they died because their heads
would have to rest on that big old red
collar while either died or became a
vampire which is something that was
incorporated into the power set of
michael morbius in marvel team up number
three and four from back in the day like
he didn't originally have the power to
turn other people into vampires because
he himself was a living vampire rather
than an undead vampire and this is a
power that is of course alluded to at
the very end of the movie with martine
bancroft's resurrection post scared leto
nibble with martinez vampiric turn being
something that happens in the comics as
well and she actually ends up becoming
an enemy to michael morbius with her
goal being to turn michael into a true
undead vampire like her because as we
see in the movie she died and came back
to life whereas michael never died but
anyways the first shot of the movie
finds us over the jungles of cerro de la
muerte costa rica with cerro de amorte
actually translating to the hill of
death which is symbolically fitting
considering how much death these bats
hiding in these mountainous hills are
about to inadvertently cause and when
morbius hops out of this n9747p
labeled helicopter a set of characters
often seen together on vehicles in
movies like this helicopter and cars he
consoles a group of costa ricans scatter
the dark by telling them that nocturnal
vampire bats can down a creature 10
times their size while the film shows
the remains of an unfortunate animal at
the mouth of this cave but hey fun fact
even though morbius himself sucks blood
vampire bats don't actually do that they
actually lick the blood off of their
victims after making small numbed cuts
on them so the fact that this creature
is nothing but bones here very much
justifies the fear of morbius's costa
rican bat trapping helpers because that
seems like one very painful way to go
and though it may seem like vampires get
their name from vampire bats it's
actually the opposite with vampire bats
being named after the fictional vampires
after 1987's dracula became so damn
popular amongst the ancestors of future
edward cullen stands people couldn't get
enough of that dracula but moving on the
movie then cuts to a flashback 25 years
in the past with a sick morbius playing
chess by himself before meeting a boy
named lucian with this lonely game of
chess sort of symbolizing how morbius
has to dedicate his life battling
himself and the mysteries of his broken
genetic code but then michael would then
of course naturally go on to call lucian
the name of a dead child named milo who
died a long time ago for the rest of
lucian's life like a normal person as
the two somehow remain best friends
despite this constant weird morbid
bullying with milo being the best friend
figure the character emile nicos was for
morbius in the comics who also
eventually gets turned into a vampire
who wants to kill morbius just like
martine bancroft kinda bad to be friends
with morbius also since i'm a big old
weirdo i also found that if you
unscramble the letters of the name emile
nicos you can actually get the term
milo's kine which can translate to no
milos in german which i thought was very
funny considering that all the milos who
weren't actually milos in this film with
you know the volusion thing but of
course in this live-action adaptation
the name emil nichols would ultimately
be given to jared harris's character the
man who would introduce morbius to his
new best friend instead of actually
being his best friend in the live-action
universe and mr emil will go on to make
everybody in the audience perk their
ears and raise their eyebrows when he
mentions a school for gifted children in
new york a huge allusion towards
professor xavier's school for gifted
youngsters that houses the mutants of
the x-men which is a wildly bold move
for sony as far as we know they have
zero rights to any of the x-men
properties considering that sony did not
buy the rights to the x-men for several
billion human dollars a couple years ago
and after the two young boys are
inexplicably targeted by bullies for
having a sickness beyond their control
morbius quotes the mantra of the famed
spartan warrior king leonidas expertly
played by gerard butler in the movie 300
where the few battle the many which is a
phrase that milo and morbius share in
the film we then flash forward to the
present day to a scene of morbius being
awarded the nobel prize for his work on
creating blue artificial blood cells
that emil notes as being responsible for
saving more lives than penicillin which
is a huge deal considering that
penicillin has been regarded as one of
the greatest medical advancements in
human history as it was literally the
beginning of human antibiotics and an
achievement that comic book morbius
succeeds with as well but unlike his
comic book counterpart scaraletto
rejects the nobel prize because while
saving all these lives were great his
main goal was to cure his disease for
the far fewer people around the world
were also afflicted because his disease
really sucks so he felt like a failure
and hey unless you have the genetically
augmented strength and endurance of
morbius you probably need a little pick
me up now and then but no need to
retreat to your science lab to find the
perfect energizing formula instead you
can just reach for the new g-fuel plasma
collectors box look at this
now mobius themed inspired by sony
pictures morbius it comes with a morbius
shaker cup and a tub of the custom
flavor plasma it's not real plasma like
blood it's just it's called it's called
plasma let's mix it up shall we
[Applause]
it's got a great nectarine flavor and
it's so fitting that it's such a
sunshiny fruit flavor for a character
that can literally walk on sunshine
through the air and it's got
antioxidants and a focus complex to help
you stay on your a-game whether you're
trying to cure yourself of a disease or
just trying to finish elden ring and g
fuels even better when you want to go
back to watch morbius again in the
theater so you can find all those
missable details and when you do just
make sure you have a shaker full of
plasma so you can have all the focus to
notice every single thing that i missed
in my breakdown so use the link in the
description or use the code new
rockstars 30 to get 30 off the
collector's box and thanks to g fuel for
sponsoring this video get yourself a
mobius cup today but the most
interesting thing of note here is this
daily bugle newspaper article underneath
all that boring nobel peace prize stuff
that notes that it has been apparently
90 days since the last sighting of a
superhero in this venom universe subtly
implying the existence of spider-man in
this universe without saying the term
spider-man you know despite all the
spider-man references in the morbius
promo material that was scrubbed from
the final product but considering what
we know from the end of the amazing
spider-man 2 that peter parker stopped
being spider-man for a period of 5
months or 152 days we could be looking
at a scenario where morbius takes place
during that five-month gap between july
2014 and january 2015 when andrew
garfield spider-man was crying over
spilled stacy's i mean oscorp did have a
file on michael morbius after all
alongside dr kirk connors aka the lizard
another scientist obsessed with splicing
human and animal dna and was actually a
very big part of morbius's origin comic
because morbius's blood was actually
some type of healing agent for lizard at
the time and with morbius having been
confirmed to be part of venom's universe
it also makes sense for them to share
andrew garfield's spider-man universe as
the amazing spider-man 2 does show us
that oscorp has a facility in eddie
brock's west coast in los angeles with
some established interest in venom and
also considering that michael keaton
vulture shows up later in the
mid-credits scenes with wings that
operate completely differently than the
vulture rings from spider-man homecoming
designed by the tinkerer this daily
bugle newspaper could actually end up
being one of the most important easter
eggs in this movie that could help us
make sense of how a wingless adrian
manages to take flight so damn fast
despite not bringing his vulture suit
with him because as we see at the end of
the amazing spider-man 2 vulture's wings
have already been made by ozcorp in
sony's universe so gustav fears probably
set that vulture man up for success
after helping tombs out of prison you
know just paying his lawyer fees and all
that so basically what i'm trying to say
here is to me sony is for sure trying to
set up an amazing spider-man 3 with
andrew garfield fighting this new
sinister 16. likely against a morbius
vulture aaron taylor johnson craven
amazing spider-man to harry osborne doc
ock because we see the legs at the end
of amazing spider-man 2 and maybe even
jake gyllenhaal's mysterio a sinister
six scenario that could actually be fun
with the right creative direction
emphasis on the right creative direction
i will literally help you write this
movie sony just hit me up but another
potential amazing spider-man easter egg
when we first meet the adult version of
milo expertly played by matt smith who
absolutely just carries this entire film
matt smith the god himself channeling
his inner goofy 11th doctor from doctor
who it's actually my favorite show of
all time let's just be real though yes
milo could easily be referring to any
sketchy russian mobsters in the world
that he pissed off during some friendly
gambling while explaining his heightened
security to morbius this could also be
an illusion towards the russian rhino
from the amazing spider-man 2's game as
a rhino easter egg can be seen next to a
picture of a new york street on a daily
bugle newspaper later on in the movie
with that street picture possibly
alluding to that last street fight
between spider-man and rhino at the end
of amazing spider-man 2. and that rhino
easter egg is next to another easter egg
alluding towards the existence of black
cat in this universe as well with the
words black cat friend or foe who could
also end up factoring into an amazing
spider-man 3 scenario if sony is
actually going down that road i mean
cindy sweeney did just join the cast of
madame webb after all and a lot of
people are hoping that she's playing
felicia hardy so maybe sony's just
setting up the seats for her right here
and i love absolutely love the repeated
doctor who easter egg throughout this
movie as we can see the clock striking
11 when we first meet the former 11th
doctor matt smith in morbius with the
clock approaching 11 earlier in the film
as a young milo first approaches to meet
a young morbius in greece and later on
in the film when milo is asked to
describe his pain from 1 to 10 matt
smith says 11. and my god should he have
winked at the camera when he did that
because my doctor who love and ass would
have ate that [ __ ] right up and when
morbius finally gets the funding that he
needs to conduct his illegal experiments
on the high seeds aboard the ship called
the murnau which is of course named
after fw marnal the first director of
1922's vampire classic nosferatu we are
set up with very similar circumstances
of morbius's origin that we find in the
pages of amazing spider-man 102 with
morbius and martine on a boat while
morbius infuses bat dna into his body
leading to a transformation that ends
with morbius experiencing his first
taste of blood and director daniel
espinosa's love for the matrix movies is
very much apparent with not just
morbius's brutal bullet-time bludgeoning
of his first victims but also through
the movie's overall theme of red versus
blue with the movie's main character
having to make this choice of red versus
blue much like neo does in the matrix
but in this situation the blue pill of
artificial blue blood is the way to go
for morbius rather than the enticing red
human blood and he even goes as far to
include a bullet timing matrix fight in
a subway between morbius and milo later
on in the movie that ends with one of
them jumping in front of a moving train
much like the neo and agent smith fight
from the first matrix film in a detail
that i found really interesting while
all of these assault rifle sailors were
being assailed by some [ __ ] is the
visual and sound design of this
particular shot here of morbius slashing
this poor brother's throat with the
sounds of blood spurting being clearly
audible however because this movie is
pg-13 no blood is actually animated in
post to actually come out of this dude
neck to you know actually make that
sound so it literally just looks like
this dude is just you know choking on a
fig newton or some [ __ ] especially since
morbius's neck slash clearly doesn't
even touch his neck smart move though
because he definitely bought himself a
few more minutes before morbius
inevitably drains all eight men of all
of their blood apparently as mentioned
by agent rodriguez a little bit later in
the film and while morbis tests out his
new vampire powers at his facilities at
horizon labs a famous laboratory from
the marvel comics filled with
cutting-edge innovations that comic book
morbius has links to we see morbius's
echolocation manifested through the use
of vibrant color and while this isn't to
the same degree as you know your average
living vampire there are actually people
in the world that can see sound and
music as color through a phenomenon
called chromosthesia which is something
that the singer lord has said has
contributed to the creation of her music
especially the song green light and of
course for the second time this week we
got a nice high anxiety light flickering
hallway scene before this nice nurse
lady is murdered by milo with moon
knight episode 1 also tapping to the
common horror troll you know like we see
played out in 2016's lights out for
example
and when morbius is arrested for milo's
murder he has a one-on-one with agent
shroud and rodriguez with the triple
blessed holy water because you gotta
have it if you're facing a vampire
one-on-one and when he does morbius
makes a direct reference to the 2008
incredible hulk film by warning the two
that they wouldn't like him when he's
hungry same problem
and while a jailbroken morbius and milo
get into that tussle on the subway
morbius walks past a poster with the
word basilisk on it a nod to the morbius
enemy basilisk a man turned monster who
debuted in the pages of morbius number 5
in the 90s possibly teasing a potential
villain for a morbius sequel and finally
the final fight of morbius ends with
morbius calling out to a swarm of bats
for bat backup batman begins style and
introduces this power to control bats
alluded to earlier in the film when he
hops into his bat tank set to a score
suspiciously similar to that of han
zinder's batman score
[Music]
when i heard that in the theater i was
like hold on hold on and of course the
movie ends with morbius stabbing his
best friend milo in the heart in
traditional vampire killing fashion
despite telling his girlfriend only
minutes ago that they weren't that kind
of vampires but hey
whatever
but that is it for this breakdown of
morbius what do you guys think of the
movie and what did you guys think of the
post-credits scene let us know in the
comment section below my beautiful nerd
babies but anyways you can follow me at
mastertainment on twitter if you want to
see me tweet some weird [ __ ] but most
importantly you can follow new rockstars
wherever we are on social media and when
you do on youtube make sure you hit that
notification bell so you can get
notifications every time we upload a
video and please make sure to hit up new
rockstarsmerch.com because we have
amazing moon night merch for moon night
season we got new shirts we got a new
hoodie which looks super fire eric was
wearing it the other day and it looks
pretty just looks pretty good i'm gonna
say so if you want to look fly like eric
voss head on over to new
rockstarsmerch.com thank you guys so
much for watching this video and for
spending time with me i really
appreciate it so much and i'll see you
guys next time goodbye
[Music]
so
[Music]